Para conocerte, entenderte,
ver cuáles son tus objetivos,
metas y lo fundamental,
no saber si realmente te podemos ayudar.
A partir de ahí te voy a hablar acerca de
quiénes somos, cómo funciona las clases,
metodología y también todo lo referente
al proceso de admisión. Vale, de acuerdo,
perfecto, muy bien. Por último, zoila,
este espacio está dedicado
específicamente para ti,
cualquier duda pregunta que tú tengas,
ninguna pregunta está de más ni mucho
menos.
Yo probablemente vaya tocando todos los
temas,
pero si vemos alguna duda específica,
la resolvemos en el momento bien.
Perdón muy bien, perfecto, excelente.
Bueno,
esto lo comentamos recién por teléfono,
pero sobre todo para la grabación,
me me decías que eres ingeniera en
marketing no tienes ninguna certificación,
metodologías ágiles, ni ni de este tipo.
Trabajas para una empresa de consumo
masivo y ventas.
Actualmente estás en un puesto de alcance
nacional,
estás como jefe nacional de en Trame
marketing y me comentabas que buscas
consolidarte el encargo,
poder especializarte,
seguir creciendo a nivel profesional.
Y sobre todo,
también con la idea de postular a una
gerencia.
Sí que sería el el puesto siguiente que
que tienes dentro del organigrama
correcto. Así es correcto, muy bien.
¿Zoila,
Cuéntame Qué qué herramientas necesitas
para para poder ser gerente de entre
marketing y marketing?
¿Allí en en la compañía y cómo se llama
la compañía? Disculpa,
en la empresa se llama Nirsa Nirsa es sí,
es una compañía de alimentos,
nos quedamos principalmente de enlatados
como atún, sardina y exportamos a muchos.
Gracias a nivel nacional manejamos otras
categorías, también de congelados y demás.
Eso es más que nada una una empresa de
consumo masivo.
Actualmente estoy en esta empresa,
anteriormente estuve en Arca continental,
Coca Cola,
manejando todo el portafolio de bebidas.
Ya hoy en día yo estoy en un puesto de
Jefatura nacional de Trade marketing y
manejo los canales de moderno y
tradicional. Entonces un poco.
Lo que buscaba es una actualizarme en las
nuevas tendencias,
obviamente un poco ampliar mi nivel de
conocimiento.
Por eso buscaba justamente una escuela de
negocio parecido, de de de allá,
porque punto de vista es donde están un
poco más actualizados y avanzados en la
parte de de mercadotecnia y demás.
Entonces para una y dos, este sí, sí,
considero que ya mi hoja de vida sí.
Cierto,
yo en su debido momento quise hacer 111
maestría prioricé un poco mi cambio de
ciudad porque yo soy de machala,
acá en Ecuador soy de machala y por
trabajo me movilicé a Guayaquil,
entonces tuve que priorizar tema de
cambio de vehículo,
cambio de compra de vivienda,
cambio de domicilio por completo,
entonces dije, bueno,
por trabajo actualmente no necesitaba en
ese debido momento este 111 título
adicional ya.
Pero hoy considero que ya lo requiero
para poder inclusive sentirme hasta más
segura en mis postulaciones,
no solamente en la compañera que soy,
sino también en algunos procesos en los
que me han llamado y quisiera que en
siguientes ocasiones estar más preparada,
solamente la parte de experiencia que
considero que es mi una de las fortalezas
que ya tengo.
Por toda mi experiencia este a lo largo
de este de estos años,
sino también ya en la parte de
conocimientos un poco ampliar mi lenguaje,
hablarlo ya de manera técnica.
Considero que de pronto tengo
conocimientos que son muy empíricos,
pero de pronto puedo ya elevarlos de
nivel en mis conversaciones.
Entonces por esa razón es que yo estoy
buscando hoy en día este 111,
retomar la parte de de de estudios y un
poco actualizarme también.
Entonces vi esta opción.
Por eso es que solicito un poco más de
información para ver si de pronto se
acopla a lo que yo hoy en día estoy
buscando bien. Bien,
por lo que me comentas es darte una base,
un background a nivel académico,
a toda esta experiencia que has ido
adquiriendo a lo largo de los años.
A partir de ahí,
justamente todas esas herramientas,
conocimientos, metodologías,
poder hablar el mismo lenguaje a la hora
de sentarte en un directorio también,
y que esto bueno te lleve a tomar
decisiones y tener mucho mayor seguridad.
También correcto.
Así es exactamente bien, bien,
excelente y siendo un poquito más
genérico. ¿Zoila,
Cuéntame cómo te sientes a nivel
planificación, a nivel estrategia,
a nivel liderazgo tienes personas a cargo
cuántas?
YY justamente con la toma de decisiones
también.
Ya actualmente tengo un equipo a mi cargo,
son cuatro personas,
pero próximamente van a ser 80
adicionales,
por eso justamente estoy buscando así
estoy buscando.
¿Que dentro de de este envío y que tenga
también hay algo, algo de liderazgo,
de pronto tomarlo de manera adicional ya
porque comento esto porque justamente en
el área de Trade este el siguiente año me
van a pasar a mi cargo todas las
promotoras a nivel nacional para poder
comprar el nivel de ejecución,
estoy actualmente,
llevo ya 5 meses en este puesto,
me dieron la oportunidad y ya he
implementado algunas algunas actividades
que nos han ayudado en el tema de
ejecución, fidelización y demás, entonces?
Al ver ese desempeño,
creo yo que están apostando a pasarme a
mí todo el equipo de promotoras al
siguiente año.
¿Entonces trabajo de manera planificada?
Soy muy estructurada y mi forma de
trabajar y de vivir.
Entonces considero que en esa parte el
también el conocimiento que tengo de la
compañía y del know how que traje de la
empresa en la que estuve.
Hoy en día el reto en la en el puesto que
yo tengo es poder implementar todas esas
actividades que ya venía haciéndolo o que
pude tener la oportunidad de implementar
en una compañía mucho más grande poder
implementarlas acá en irsa,
entonces ese es mi reto para en lo que
corresponde a mi puesto y dentro de mi
planeación del 2026,
mi plan de try justamente abarca muchas
de estas actividades, todo lo que es.
Manuales de ejecución perfecta,
todo lo que corresponde a planes de
Fidelización para tener mayorista.
Entonces en ese aspecto considero que en
la parte de planeación,
estructuración estoy bien,
creo considero que solo puedo mejorar,
obviamente con los conocimientos que que
1 tiene,
pues en la parte de estudios suma
muchísimo y en la parte de liderazgo
estoy aprendiendo,
o sea aprendiendo a liderar ya equipos.
De alto nivel porque no es lo mismo
liderar un equipo de coordinadores.
Ayer lideraron un equipo de jefes de Tris
regionales,
que es lo que el reto que actualmente
tengo y para el siguiente año el reto que
se me viene de tener a cargo 80.
Este mercaderistas o promotoras como lo
conocen allá,
pero también es algo que en lo que siento
que ya me tengo que ir preparando.
Por eso es que dije,
tengo que hoy es el momento.
¿Tengo que buscar ya el poder este
actualizarme en conocimientos y a su vez
también este desempolvar,
porque a veces 1 por la la calle es una
buena escuela,
pero la parte pues de conocimientos y
demás es algo que que 1 no debe de de
pagar, no?
Además se va actualizando permanentemente,
sobre todo cómo van cambiando los
mercados y demás,
y esto lo bueno también que va a haber
zoila,
que aquí tiene una visión mucho más
global, más internacional, más periférica,
más 360.
La idea es que no solamente aprendas del
programa en sí de los profesores del
director,
sino también de todos tus compañeros.
Verás que aquí en las aulas tenemos entre
20 y 25 diferentes nacionalidades.
Y eso hace justamente que que tenga mucho
más herramientas y una visión mucho más
amplia,
porque generalmente lo que pasa es que 1
tiene estudios de de su propio país,
que no es que esté bien ni mal,
ni que sea buena ni mala,
sino que simplemente tiene una única
visión. No es cierto,
en este caso amplias, mucho.
Tu tu campo de de visión y sobre todo a
nivel de estrategia,
planificación también te da muchas más
herramientas. Última pregunta,
soy la antes de ya de de pasar a
compartirte pantalla a hacer la
presentación.
¿Te quería preguntar en estas,
en este tiempo que has estado viendo
alternativas de maestría a nivel local,
ha sido a nivel local o aquí en Europa
también? ¿Con qué te habías encontrado?
De momento bueno,
hice juntas a nivel local,
pero mi primera fue este exterior y ya vi
otras opciones también que justamente
tengo programadas el día de hoy.
También un poco poder tener esta llamada
y poder escuchar.
Un poco el plan de de estudios hoy es
feria acá en Ecuador,
por eso es que puedo,
puedo puedo atender toda la cara en mi
tranquilidad porque dije,
en estos 2 días me dedico a buscar YY
tiene que salir la opción en estos días.
Entonces sí he estado buscando mi primera
opción, siempre va a ser,
es una Escuela de Negocios exterior
porque considero aparte.
Sigo mucho, la verdad,
las modalidades online y toda la la,
la información que está colgada en
algunos sitios,
en algunas entonces me interesa mucho
porque he visto la diferencia entre lo
que ya están en tendencias de estudio
allá y mercados,
allá versus lo que hay acá en Ecuador.
Entonces sí considero que para mí sería
un plus.
¿Y de aquí a con quién habías visto que
tenías programadas algunas reuniones de
acuerdas,
las escuelas o las universidades?
Sí, sí, sí, hay una,
este que me interesó mucho,
que es la Universidad de Valencia que
está.
Tengo igualmente la llamada más tarde,
pero y esta de aquí pues o ese que es una
de mis primeras opciones también bien,
bien, excelente. Ahora te voy a comentar,
sobre todo soy la de que que veas cuál es
la diferencia entre una entre hacer una
maestría en una Universidad y una Escuela
de Negocios. Ya hay una gran diferencia,
pero además si lo comparas con nosotros.
No somos ninguna de las dos,
somos una Escuela de Negocios de alta
dirección.
Entonces verás que tienes un mundo
infinito de de diferencias porque te da
muchísimas más herramientas que cuando
generalmente en una Universidad tienes un
plan de estudios, un programa que empieza,
finaliza y ya se acaba.
¿Generalmente tu relación sí,
te estoy compartiendo pantalla,
tú puedes verla correctamente bien,
vamos a comenzar por el principio,
entonces, primero que nada,
quiénes somos nosotros? ¿Sí,
nosotros formamos parte de lo que es
Grupo Planeta,
te suena Grupo Planeta a ti?
Ligeramente, mira a ver si lo relacionas.
Grupo Planeta es un grupo solvente,
muy reconocido a nivel mundial,
tiene 3 grandes líneas de negocio,
la primera, la de toda la vida,
quizás te suene, editoriales, planetas,
enciclopedias, los libros, sí, no,
y es algo excelente, sí, tal cual bueno,
también tenemos lo que es la división
audiovisual a la cual pertenece la
productora atresmedia que he hecho aquí
en España es muy famosa,
quizá a TI también te suene, porque bueno,
aquí tiene radio, televisión, multimedia,
Antena 3, cadena 6.
Pero produjo, por ejemplo,
la serie Netflix, la casa de papel,
lo VIS a VIS y lo que es la división,
formación y educación a la cual pertenece
o b s nosotros hoy la somos justamente un
holding de 22 escuelas de negocios y
decir así como o b, s tenemos 21 más,
pasa que tenemos cada una en su
especialidad. Tenemos, por ejemplo,
en la parte de diseño,
en la parte culinaria alta cocina tenemos
en la parte de idiomas.
Y o b s lo que te comentaba recién es una
escuela de alta dirección
profesionalizante, es decir,
no somos ni solamente una Universidad ni
solo una Escuela de Negocios,
sino que además nos dedicamos
específicamente a esto que tú estás
buscando a preparar perfiles para que
ocupen cargos gerenciales,
cargos directivos. Sí,
hemos nacido allí por el año 2006 como la
primera escuela 100% Online en español,
no solamente el Grupo de estas 22 que te
comento, sino a nivel mundial.
De hecho,
Fíjate el nombre o b s significa online
Business School,
que quiero decir con esto que tenemos
hemos nacido de esta manera,
tenemos desde el minuto cero preparada.
Tenemos incluso registrada y patentada
nuestra metodología online. Entonces,
por ahí les llevamos muchísimos años de
ventaja a muchas universidades que por
ahí sí que son reconocidas o prestigiosas,
pero que se han dedicado toda la vida a
la formación presencial y quizá debido a
la pandemia, por ejemplo,
tuvieron que hacer ese cambio,
no ese switch de pasar de sus planes
físicos de manera online.
Bueno,
nosotros ya tenemos más de 42000 alumnos
profesionales que se han formado y
egresado con nosotros de más de 80
nacionalidades.
El 78% de nuestros alumnos son directivos.
A nivel metodología,
como te comentaba perdón,
la tenemos registrada y patentada.
Se llama Student on. Bueno,
primero que nada está reconocida por 5
estrellas QS Start de QS Start Writing
System. Ahora más bien,
este ranking está avalada por profesores
practitionans el cien por cien de tus
profesores,
además de ser docentes y esto también una
ventaja de tienes respecto a una
Universidad en sí.
Que generalmente suelen ser académicos o
catedráticos.
No tiene nada de malo no ser docente,
pero digo,
hay muchos de ellos que a lo mejor te van
a dar una clase a ti y que jamás en su
vida pisar una compañía privada.
Tú imagínate que tiene para aportarte a
lo mejor sí, a nivel teórico,
pero hoy por hoy, por Internet,
inteligencia artificial y demás,
no tiene sentido.
Lo que necesitamos es el la experiencia.
¿Cómo puedo aplicar todo lo aprendido
dentro de mi puesto de trabajo y de forma
inmediata? ¿No?
Esto es un método ágil, flexible,
colaborativo, 100% online.
Aquí ese módulo estructurado de 10
módulos porque se refiere programa
estructurado de 10 módulos.
Perdón porque se refiere a las maestrías,
en el caso del m B I = 20 módulos
consecutivos Comienzas en abril,
Finalizas en abril del 2027,
duró 1 año únicamente.
Esto también sobre todo si lo comparas a
nivel local.
Que generalmente primero que nada va a
ser presencial,
entonces tiene que trasladar y demás más
estudiarlo en tu casa y además suelen ser
2 años.
Entonces la diferencia termina siendo
abismal. En cuanto a lo que es el tiempo,
tenemos dos pilares fundamentales que nos
destacan sobre el resto de las
universidades. Hoy la del primero,
seguimiento personalizado aquí te vas a
encontrar con aulas reducidas de 4550
personas, máximo.
¿Y me dirás, Iván, Qué tiene de novedoso?
Seamos 4550 personas. Bueno,
esto que te decía,
recién hay mucha escuela de negocio,
nueva escuela de negocio de Garage.
Le llamamos aquí que pecan de ser online.
Como no tienes que llenar un espacio
físico con personas.
¿Esto tú no lo sabes,
pero luego te encuentras en una primer
clase que tiene 150 o 200 compañeros,
Imagínate, en una clase, hora,
hora y media saben a donde va a estar
hablando el docente?
Tú tienes una pregunta,
pero tiene 150 personas delante de TI y
se hace prácticamente imposible de
participar. Muy caótico, muy impersonal,
aquí buscamos literalmente lo opuesto,
calidad y no cantidad. Tú tienes una duda,
levantas la mano,
te responden automáticamente,
trato directo 1 a 1, tú,
tú con el docente, De hecho,
vas a tener un tutor académico designado
exclusivamente para ti,
nosotros lo llamamos Program Manager.
Es la figura que te va a guiar y dar
apoyo durante todo el programa para que
comiences,
sobre todo finalices el programa con
éxito. ¿Cómo lo vas a hacer?
Esto a través de casos reales, talleres,
Business,
planes y debates a través de simuladores
y softwares, nuestro partner académico,
bueno, la UB,
la Universidad de Barcelona y esa otra
ventaja que tienes aquí,
porque lo que te decía,
no somos solo una Escuela de Negocios,
sino además también tenemos a a la UB.
No sé si tenías algún tipo de referencia
sobre Universidad de Barcelona. Maga,
el nombre me refiero.
Sí, sí, sí había deseado,
incluso por el habido momento.
¿Era una opción para mí para poder hacer
la maestría allá,
pero por qué más de tiempo así?
Bueno,
Universidad de Barcelona es una de las
universidades más antiguas de de toda
Europa,
inclusive tiene más de 560 años de
historia.
Una Universidad se caracteriza por ser
innovadora, de excelencia académica.
Bueno,
a nivel rankings está ranking dentro de
mejores 150 universidades del planeta
dentro de las mejores 30 Europa y es la
Universidad número 1 de aquí de España.
En ese sentido justamente te daban mucho
prestigio, mucho reconocimiento.
Te va a abrir muchas puertas a nivel
networking también. Bueno,
nosotros hacemos mucho énfasis,
mucho foco en esto.
Sí y bueno,
inclusive a a nivel reconocimiento,
rankings. No,
no me quiero detener mucho en esto,
pero es cierto,
formamos parte prácticamente de todos los
rankings a nivel internacional.
Para mí estos son los más destacados,
ranking de Forbes,
Financial Times Magazine,
universal El Mundo y este que te mencioné
recién el QS Star Rating system.
El ranking más prestigioso que existe a
nivel internacional dentro de lo que es
la formación online es bastante complejo
siquiera ingresar en el ranking.
No solamente hemos ingresado,
sino que además obtuvimos la categoría
máxima 5 estrellas en lo que es la
categoría online learning.
Eso me refiero a la escuela, sí,
a o b s bien, y luego además de eso,
nosotros manejamos casi 40 programas
entre maestrías YMBS.
¿Y de esos 40,
únicamente 3 programas están rankeados
aquí en el QS Star y Adivina cuál es 1 de
ellos,
el exit kit de M B A para nosotros viene
a ser como la joya de la corona realmente
porque es 1 de los programas que es mejor,
está rankeado a nivel internacional? Bien,
bien,
voy a pasar a lo que es la plataforma,
mira a ver aquí nosotros utilizamos.
Blackboard es la líder mundial de
plataformas de aprendizaje,
que es todas las herramientas
centralizadas aquí.
Vas a tener,
De hecho verás aquí ahora cuando se abra,
este es mi usuario soila,
aquí lo vas a ver porque yo he finalizado
una una maestría hace poquito tiempo,
así que bueno,
te puedo hacer mucho en primera persona
como funciona todo.
Si desde ya decirte formato muy flexible
te va a permitir compaginar tu vida
profesional, tu vida académica,
tener tu vida privada también.
Por supuesto vas a tener 20 módulos como
te comentaba,
estos son dos módulos por cada mes,
siempre con el foco en la progresión y la
coherencia pedagógica.
¿Qué significa esto?
Cada asignatura las vas a ir pulsando de
forma consecutiva, es decir, en abril,
módulo 1 y dos, en mayo 3 y cuatro,
junio 5 y 6 y así sucesivamente para que
tú te puedas focalizar y conseguir los
mejores resultados.
Si bien en un semestre vas a tener 10
asignaturas,
las vas teniendo de a dos por mes,
así justamente puedes tener los mejores
resultados y no tienes días al mismo
tiempo.
Entonces tienes que hacer un trabajo 1 en
un entrega de otro.
Una clase se entiende que sea mucho más
pedagógico.
Vas a tener un planning como este que
puedes ver en pantalla con todos los
horarios detallados,
baila para que tú organices y te
planifiques con tiempo.
Es realmente muy sencillo organizarte
porque tienes dos masterclass por semana
únicamente.
Esto es en vivo y en directo en tiempo
real.
Alumnos y docentes suele ser entre las 7
y las 8:00 h España,
que son entre la una y las 14:00 h de la
tarde hora Ecuador,
una vez a la semana 1 hora,
perdón dos veces a la semana 1 hora 1:30
H Vale cada una.
Pero bueno, tú me dirás, Iván,
yo a esa ahora a veces estoy trabajando,
tengo reuniones algo imprevisto,
lo que fuera. Bueno, no te preocupes,
no hay un horario de conexión obligatoria,
no hay asistencia,
no se te va a tomar listas,
no se te descuentan puntos o k.
La clase es y se graba en vivo y en
directo,
pero tú luego la puedes revisar en
diferido en cualquier momento. Sí,
básicamente el n b a se ajusta a ti,
no tu,
el n b a funciona como un traje hecho a
tu medida y aquí, sin ir más lejos,
te doy mi propio ejemplo, Zoila,
nosotros como trabajamos con Ecuador,
tenemos 6 horas con Colombia,
también con México 7 de diferencia.
¿He trabajado por la tarde,
yo literalmente el 100% del programa
estaba trabajando, qué hacía?
Lo vi todo en diferido.
A veces va ir a la clase a la noche o a
lo mejor al día siguiente a la mañana,
incluso si te una semana complicada la
veis el fin de semana. ¿Por qué?
Porque la unidad electiva es semanal.
¿Zoila, cómo te van a evaluar a ti? Bueno,
primero que nada,
olvídate esto de la Universidad,
no de tener que estudiar,
memorizar y luego repetir, sino todo.
Por el contrario,
un enfoque mucho más pragmático,
mucho más práctico. ¿De hecho,
trabajamos lo que es el método del caso,
el método Harvard,
pero digo a nivel de evaluación,
cómo te van a evaluar? Va a dar 3 maneras.
En la masterclass el docente desarrolla
un tema y una vez que finaliza la la
clase deja colgadas 3 cuatro preguntas en
un foro,
en un debate donde tú vas a tener 3
cuatro participaciones a lo largo de la
semana de manera escrita, el docente,
bueno,
vas a tener feedback de tus compañeros,
el docente actúa como moderador,
luego tendrás algún que otro test,
pero sobre todo soy la vas a resolver
actividades.
Sí que estas actividades son casos reales,
ahora vamos a eso.
Pero supongamos, la clase es el miércoles,
Tú vas a tener hasta el martes siguiente
a las 12:00 H de la noche,
hora España para dejar resuelta esa
actividad. Entonces,
si es lo que te decía,
si tú lo quieres hacer el miércoles a la
noche, jueves por la mañana,
el domingo o el mismo martes a las 23:00
H de la noche,
ya depende de ti el traje hecho a tu
medida que te comentaba, vale, a nivel,
metodología, método,
el caso método Harvard,
no sé si lo conocía,
lo habías utilizado o sería la primera
vez sí lo había, sí, lo había ahí.
La empresa anterior actualmente no es
tanto, pero en la empresa anterior sí,
sí lo había escuchado. Ajá. ¿Bueno, mira,
cien por cien de tus profesores son
profesores en activo,
profesores practitioners,
qué significa esto? ¿Son especialistas,
conocen perfectamente las tendencias del
mercado,
tiene entre 15 y 20 años de experiencia
del sector privado,
así que siempre vas a trabajar en base a
casos reales,
donde tú en determinada situación,
con determinadas herramientas en
diferentes escenarios,
vas a ir tomando decisiones
permanentemente,
viendo cómo impactaría cada una de ellas
en la vida real, porque y para que?
¿Esto, zoila,
para que tú veas lo que es la
aplicabilidad inmediata, no?
¿Cómo puedo aplicar todos estos
conocimientos, metodologías, herramientas,
actualizaciones,
softwares dentro de mi puesto de trabajo
y de forma inmediata y que eso,
por supuesto,
traiga los resultados que tú estás
buscando, no? Y a su vez,
este programa específicamente maneja un
software de simulación que se llama voz.
Son las siglas en inglés Blue Oceans
Strategy Simulation, donde.
A través de un algoritmo y la
inteligencia artificial vas a tener
diferentes escenarios adversos.
Vas a ocupar un cargo directivo y vas a
ir tomando decisiones permanentemente y
viendo el impacto real que tiene cada una
de ellas. ¿Cuál es la idea de todo esto?
Zoila,
que tú aquí en este entorno educativo,
un entorno seguro,
tomes decisiones asertivas, te equivoques,
te van a forzar a que te equivoques a
veces porque.
Porque donde 1 realmente aprende,
no en el error. Entonces el día de mañana,
cuando ya enfrente este tipo de cargo,
ya sea gerente de Trend marketing a nivel
nacional, bueno,
ya sepas qué decisión de tomar,
qué departamento vincular,
qué herramienta utiliza, es decir,
minimizar el riesgo justamente al mínimo
posible.
Bien te gusta lo que es la metodología en
ese sentido se se adapta a lo que tú
estabas buscando. Sí,
es me me me gusta porque es muy
direccionado en lo práctico y a caso es
real escala final es lo que.
O sea,
yo ya estoy en un nivel profesional y es
por eso mi interés.
Entonces se adapta mucho a lo que a lo
que estoy necesitando, excelente,
excelente soy la yo, tengo el programa,
sé que te lo envié hace minutos,
no sé si a TI te dio tiempo de revisarlo
o quieres que lo repasemos brevemente,
juntos, brevemente, brevemente, pronto.
Lo porque no, sí, la verdad.
Lo lo lo lo ves tranquila,
pero yo por todo lo que tú me venías
diciendo,
realmente lo lo veo primero que nada.
El programa muy alineado,
pero sobre todo la escuela,
por todo esto que me comentabas también
quiere desarrollar la parte de liderazgo,
quiere tener nuevas herramientas y demás,
que ahora voy a pasar eso,
pero veamos primero el programa aquí lo
que me interesa es que haya un match por
ambas partes. Mira,
primer bloque se llama fundamentos
analíticos,
vas a ver entorno económico global,
diseño organizacional.
Diagnóstico financiero y marketing de la
idea al mercado es el primer bloque,
segundo bloque,
concepción estratégica va a ver dirección
e innovación estratégica,
gestión financiera corporativa,
estrategias de internacionalización y
marketing global.
¿Ustedes también tienen un alcance a
nivel internacional? Sí, excelente bien,
dirección de personas y gestión del
talento,
operaciones y supply chain Management.
Y digital marketing Strategies. Sí,
como verás vas tocando y sobre todo ahora
lo vamos a ver en la parte del Management,
esto que te decía por teléfono,
ahora vamos a ver el a D n de una
compañía sobre la vamos a ver todas las
áreas de una unidad de negocio. Sí,
así el día de mañana tú no solamente vas
a pasar a poder ser gerente de Trade
marketing,
sino además también el día de mañana ya
va a cargos directivos.
Te vamos a preparar directamente para eso,
para que puedas dirigir una compañía,
sobre todo en tu caso estás en una
compañía.
¿Cuántos empleos son actualmente?
Cerca de 7008 1000 empleados.
Ana compañía gigantesca soy la y tiene
realmente oportunidad de crecimiento.
Bueno,
aquí vas a ir directamente a ese tipo de
cargos,
también es lo que te va a avalar y te va
a permitir este programa. Sí,
vas a ver la parte del Manager.
Vamos a ver estrategias de transformación
digital,
análisis de datos para la toma de
decisiones,
algo que también me hacía énfasis
hincapié no en por tomar la decisión con
mucho mayor seguridad.
Cross cultural Management,
tú sabrás perfectamente.
No es lo mismo trabajar con gente de
Ecuador que de Colombia, de México,
Estados Unidos,
ni aquí a Europa en menos de Asia,
por ejemplo.
Planificación y control de gestión,
dirección comercial y gestión de ventas,
que esto también es algo que siempre va
muy cercano,
no a lo que es el marketing en la parte
comercial,
valoración de de inversiones y portfolio
Management y mercados monetarios y de
capitales por último.
Desarrollo de habilidades directivas,
vamos a ver liderazgo y gestión del
cambio,
negociación y gestión de conflictos y
también iniciativa emprendedora.
Te vamos a preparar también para el día
de mañana. Si quieres emprender,
que tengas todas las herramientas de cómo
poder hacerlo,
cómo y sobre todo aterrizar cualquier
proyecto que tú tengas bien así a simple
vista. ¿Zoila, cómo lo ves?
El programa lo lo ves alineado,
te haces sentido, sí,
súper alineado a lo que estoy buscando,
así es y verdad que perfil.
Definitivamente es lo que desea en la
descripción. Es un perfil muy este,
alineado como que el al al tema de
negocios y para hacerse totalmente
excelente, excelente soy la mira.
Aquí desde o b s te ofrecemos doble
titulación propia, sí, es decir,
dos instituciones, doble cartón,
doble diploma.
Nuestros títulos están enmarcados dentro
de lo que es el Espacio Europeo educativo
superior,
lo cual a TI te garantiza la excelencia
académica.
Te otorga 60 créditos de CTS,
que es el sistema de crédito europeo y
bueno, por supuesto,
tiene validez a nivel internacional.
Va sellado y apostillado a través del
Convenio de La Haya, del cual tu país,
Ecuador, también forma parte,
te vas a abrir en Ecuador, en México,
Estados Unidos, aquí, en Europa,
en los 150 países que forman parte del
Convenio de La Haya.
Entiendo por todo lo que hemos comentado
sobre todo lo que son tus objetivos,
metas a nivel profesional.
¿El título lo buscas para poder crecer y
trascender en El Mundo empresarial?
No es cierto,
en el sector privado me refiero.
No lo buscas ni para ser docente,
ni investigadora, ni un doctorado,
ni un cargo público correcto por el
momento es en la parte profesional, o sea,
más adelante.
Sí quisiera como que seguir seguir como
que algún otra tema de de de estudios.
Pero actualmente es eso en realidad y mi
proyección no solamente es aquí en
Ecuador,
sino que también poder utilizarlo en
otras partes, en otros países.
Por eso me interesó mucho.
La parte de este certificado de Laya,
porque sí estoy investigando y me sirve,
quedó para o sea aquí en Ecuador o
también si es que se me llegar alguna
oportunidad en otro país cercano, bien,
bien, bien, excelente, excelente,
perfecto.
Vamos alineados en en ese sentido muy
bien.
Y sí,
sobre todo si el día de mañana tú tú
quieres trabajar en el exterior,
tener una doble titulación internacional
te va a abrir muchísimas puertas. Además,
también hablemos a nivel red de contactos,
no,
en ese sentido también te da muchísisimas
herramientas. Bien, zoila, mira,
aquí vamos a pasar a lo que para mí es la
la parte más interesante de todo esto que
que estamos comentando.
Recuerdas que tengo diciendo hace desde
el principio de la reunión,
es una escuela de alta dirección,
pero qué significa esto,
escuela de alta dirección
profesionalizante, no, bueno,
ahora lo vamos a a entender.
Mucho mejor porque y esto que por ahí sí
que te comentaba al principio,
tú en cualquier Universidad,
cuando te matriculas tienes una fecha de
inicio,
una fecha de fin y se acaba tu relación
con esa Universidad. No es que esté bien,
no es que esté mal en lo que ocurre si es
el servicio que brinda una Universidad.
En este caso vas a tener por supuesto ese
servicio de desarrollo académico,
pero sobre todo también vas a tener un
servicio de desarrollo profesional donde
lo que buscamos es que tu perfil crezca
360°,
en la que desarrolle diferentes
habilidades diferentes oskits que te
hagan crecer a nivel profesional y a
nivel personal también. ¿Cómo?
A través de diferentes actividades pre
máster durante el máster y sobre todo
también de por vida sobre la pues te vas
a poder seguir formando y actualizando de
por vida. Esto es algo muy importante,
mira de aquí hasta abril.
¿No es que no vas a hacer nada,
De hecho tienes varios Boot Camps,
talleres premaster que vas a ir
desarrollando, son opcionales, no?
Evidentemente nosotros te ponemos todas
las herramientas para que tú te
desarrolles. Saludo, depende de cada 1,
vale,
pero sí que vas a tener muchísima opción.
De hecho,
tenemos un un curso ahora de Yemenine de
la inteligencia artificial en noviembre
también vas a tener sobre todo zoila,
si tú quieres crecer a nivel profesional.
Esto es algo indispensable,
tienes que desarrollar tu marca personal.
Sí, no sólo como empresa,
sino tú como marca. Bien,
nosotros seríamos como va a tener un
taller de personal branding.
Vas a tener otro de data storytelling
para que mejores tus habilidades
comunicativas a nivel interno externo de
la compañía vas a tener otro de
pensamiento creativo e innovación,
e incluso también de inteligencia
artificial generativa ingeniería de proms.
A su vez,
tendrás un boot Camp sobre capacitación
al campo virtual a la plataforma hacia
parte el día cero sabe utilizarlo de
forma óptima y esta me parece muy
interesante. Se llama PDP.
De hecho se te otorga un certificado,
un diploma por parte de o b s donde mano
a mano con un docente solo la va a
desarrollar diferentes habilidades como
gestión del tiempo, la productividad,
gestión del estrés y la inteligencia
emocional. Fíjate todo esto,
todavía ni siquiera empezó el programa
para que tenga una idea.
Luego,
luego durante el programa sí que tienes
algunos Boot Camps que van paralelos al
programa. Estos sí que son obligatorios,
pues son complementarios del contenido.
¿Tienes unos sobre desarrollo directivo?
Este es muy interesante porque
básicamente es para que interiorices todo
el conocimiento que vas adquiriendo lo
largo de todo el programa y lo puedes
llevar a la práctica. Sí,
pasar de la teoría, la práctica, sí,
a todas tus herramientas del liderazgo y
directivas.
Luego tienes cómo hacer negocios 1 y dos.
Este es muy bueno porque vas a ver las
peculiaridades económicas, culturales,
de subcultura y la influencia que tienen
las relaciones comerciales en diferentes
áreas de de todo El Mundo. Sí,
sobre todo lo que hablamos,
esto de internacionalización. De hecho,
aquí mira lo tienes a Tom van der Heiden.
Tom van der Heiden era el director de 2
programas aquí en obedece de
transformación digital,
también de innovación y emprendimiento.
¿Dejó de serlo por una cuestión de agenda?
Él es belga. Políglo,
tabla 7 idiomas tiene una consultora de
compra en el mercado asiático. Bueno,
realmente un perfil muy interesante,
al igual que el resto de los docentes. Sí,
y bueno también tiene por último
responsabilidad corporativa y sostenible,
que está muy en auge.
Hace ya bastante tiempo aquí en Europa y
también hace un buen tiempo en América
Latina,
sobre todo para que tengas herramientas
en en básicamente todas las áreas de de
la compañía, como te comentaba.
Bien hemos hablado premaster durante el
máster,
Fíjate ahora la cantidad de servicios
extracurriculares que te va a brindar o b
s nosotros tenemos una comunidad alumni.
Zoila está formada por más de 42000
alumnos profesionales y ex alumnos
también de todas partes del mundo,
donde lo que buscamos es que tu
desarrolles dos grandes áreas,
1 networking,
red de contactos a nivel local a nivel
internacional y dos el life Long learning.
Esto que te decía recién la formación
continua de por vida mira, De hecho,
nosotros en los países que más alumnos
tenemos, como es el caso de Ecuador.
Tenemos además presencia física,
tenemos un Presidente se encarga de
organizar diferentes actividades de forma
presencial. Si no puedes asistir también,
siempre puede ser de hacerlo de de manera
virtual. Tenemos aquí en España,
tenemos en Colombia,
allí en Ecuador lo tenemos a Carlos
Aguilera,
él está como manager en Billsurce,
tenemos en México, en Perú, en Chile,
Argentina, en Costa Rica.
Vamos a ir abriendo en diferentes partes
del mundo, pero mira,
te lo voy a enseñar un poquito más
gráfico desde la plataforma,
voy a volverla a la plataforma.
Incluso también algo muy interesante.
Mira,
nosotros tenemos un un site que se llama
Alumni justamente que vendría a ser como
un LinkedIn interno para darle una
referencia. Sí,
donde tienes un directorio de más de 80
países. Mira,
en este caso está filtrado por Colombia.
Es cierto que Colombia es el segundo país
que más alumnos tenemos,
luego de de España.
Y ve viendo también los cargos que tienen
cada 1 de de los que.
De los alumnos que tenemos aquí,
plan Manager, Coordinador,
coordinador comercial, Presidente,
Vicepresidente, analista financiero,
general, manager, director,
analista de marketing. Bueno,
así 70 países, perdón, 70 páginas, sí,
solo de Colombia en este caso busquémoslo
también por Ecuador también tenemos
muchísimos alumnos,
no temperamento que van a 70, pero bueno,
seguramente vamos a tener muchos allí
también. Mira, Ecuador.
66. Bueno,
está casi como Colombia prácticamente.
Y de vuelta ves aquí vas a poder hacer un
un bueno, un networking impresionante.
Realmente sí,
pero vamos a hacer un poquito más gráfico.
Mira, venimos al al apartado alumni.
Tenemos alumni. Bueno,
ahora tenemos alumni Days,
que por ejemplo en noviembre lo vamos a
tener a Isaac Hernández.
Él trabaja en Google y nos va a dar una
conferencia sobre inteligencia artificial
para un futuro sostenible.
Estuvimos teniendo durante todo el año y
acuérdate que de por vida no tiene ningún
tipo de coste. Tenemos alumni Welcome.
¿Conoces Barcelona zaila has venido? No,
no he tenido la oportunidad,
pero está dentro de mis proyectos del
2026.
Bueno,
quizá lo tengas que retrasar un poquito
para el 2027 o es algo que quiera venir
dos veces a ver si te damos una buena
excusa para que tengas oportunidad.
Fíjate, esto es el acto de graduación,
un acto de de negocio muy emotivo.
Viene entre 2503 1000 personas de todas
partes del mundo.
Digo muy emotivo porque le pones cara a
tus compañeros, los docentes,
al director del programa con los cuales
has ido trabajando durante todo el año y
además tienes la posibilidad de
participar de una semana inmersiva. Sí,
no solo este acto,
que generalmente dura 3 horas,
es un día y ya, sino también.
De venir a este año, por ejemplo,
fueron a visitar el hub tecnológico del
Fútbol Club Barcelona,
hicieron visitas a compañías tecnológicas,
tuvieron talleres de inteligencia
artificial, actividades culturales.
O realmente si la posibilidad vale
muchísimo la pena,
en este caso sería julio del 2027.
¿Por eso te decía,
de retrasarlo o que venga dos veces, vale?
Así que si si tiene la oportunidad,
vale mucho la pena.
Y ahora Fíjate la cantidad de servicios
extracurriculares que te brinda la
escuela de aquí de vuelta.
Le vamos a dar sentido a esto de escuela
de de alta dirección, Fíjate,
vas a tener por ejemplo,
Master Clases en vivo.
Ahora en noviembre tenemos una que es muy
interesante en busca de tuik Guy,
Tu propósito de vida en febrero,
inteligencia artificial para la búsqueda
de empleo y así vas teniendo durante todo
el año. ¿Acuérdate que de por vida,
pero para mí lo más importante es esto,
tú me decías que tienes actualmente
cuatro personas a cargo y probablemente
dentro de breves vas a tener 84, no?
Y tú sabrás.
Ya tengo cuatro jefes y dos analistas y
coordinadores, o sea son 6 en total,
ya y más,
o sea de manera indirecta entre se se
trabaja con gerencias y facturas,
pero ese es mi personal directo,
ya para el siguiente año son 80 personas
más que se me suman a mi nómina. Bueno,
tú lo sabrás perfectamente,
soy las 6 personas son 6 mundos
diferentes, hay que saber motivar,
gestionar,
liderar y sobre todo lo que decía,
no cuando ya cambia de rango,
pues no es lo mismo.
Manejar jefes,
que es un equipo que que te pertenece
100% a ti.
Entonces ya nosotros te te vamos a dar
apoyo en todas estas aristas. Sí,
por ejemplo vas a tener y esto es lo que
te decía,
que cuando tú me habías comentado todas
las necesidades que tú tenías,
veía que realmente hace muy buen match
con con la escuela por por esto de ser de
alta dirección, porque por ejemplo,
tienes workshops de motivación y gestión
de equipos, tienes workshop de liderazgo.
Estás en una compañía gigantesca también
sobre la vas a tener workshop de oratoria,
tú no sabes no cuando tienes que hablar
frente de muchísimas personas.
Diagnóstico de tu currículum vitae si el
día de mañana también te quieres cambiar
de compañía de cargo, lo que sea,
te hacemos un perfilaje sí de para el
cargo,
compañía y país específico el cual estás
postulando.
Así puedo obtener ese cargo en particular
y esto es que es excelente.
Si bien has ido creciendo,
has ido adquiriendo herramientas y demás.
Tampoco es que ha nacido siendo gerente
de Trend marketing a nivel nacional de
una compañía multinacional. No es cierto,
esto se desarrolla, esto se aprende.
Bueno,
nosotros acompañamos básicamente la mano
en ese crecimiento profesional.
Soila vas a tener exective Coaching,
tienes la oportunidad de cuatro sesiones
One to One.
Con un coach Ejecutivo para que
desarrolle habilidades directivas y de
liderazgo para ser gerente de Trend
marketing en Mirsa,
Ecuador se entiende en El País compañía y
cargo específico al cual has postulado o
que incluso ya has obtenido.
Sí lo puedes solicitar en cualquier
momento. Vale, excelente, zoila,
qué dudas,
qué preguntas tienes hasta aquí antes ya
de pasar a lo que es el proceso de
admisión para ir finalizando.
En la que corresponde a la parte de la
malla.
¿La verdad es que me queda sumamente
claro,
entiendo que el período de estudios es el
mes de abril,
el mes hasta el mes de abril,
el 2027 correcto al 2027, verdad?
¿Y qué perdón, la última parte,
la grabación es en julio del 2026,
correcto, verdad? Y esa es esa,
es allá en Barcelona. Entonces, exacto,
me queda sumamente clara este y tenía una
duda, la verdad es que como recién estoy.
¿Borrando opciones de esas opciones,
como que de estudio una parte no,
si esto de aquí esto de aquí sirve para
posterior hacer algún tema de o sea,
no es igual que una maestría,
entiendo verdad?
En el caso de que quiera hacer algún tipo
de doctorado o alguna especialización,
esto esta parte como que me quedó la duda
por algo no, igualmente no,
no te va a servir para hacer un doctorado,
no es no solo que no es igual a una
maestría,
sino que es superior a una maestría. Sí,
el MBI es bastante,
De hecho está la altura de un doctorado,
yo lo que te iba a decir son cosas
totalmente paralelas, bailar en tu caso.
No tiene ningún tipo de sentido que te
dediques.
Cuatro 5 años a hacer un doctorado en una
carrera de investigación.
¿Cuando está El Mundo de los negocios no
tienen absolutamente nada,
nada que ver contigo esto, De hecho,
está la altura de un doctorado,
pero más justamente por el sector privado
y por el lado del Business,
qué es lo que tú buscas?
El crecimiento me quedó como ahí porque
decía, de pronto la la no sé,
la me arriesgué teniendo,
o sea un compañero de trabajo en un rato
que estudió allá, pero de manera.
¿Ya entonces mi duda era un poco, pues mi,
mi duda sí se da de que el título que yo
tenga ya me sirva,
acá este te va a servir y De hecho
nosotros hemos sido,
yo sé que por usted es muy importante el
senecyt también, no?
Y nosotros hemos sido partícipes y
generalmente siempre se habían podido
registrar los títulos de de o b s con la
Universidad de Barcelona hubo un periodo,
fueron 3 o 4 años del 2020,
el 2000 o el 2019, perdón,
el 2022 más o menos.
Que el cambio de gobierno o no,
no sé cuál es el cambio de normativa,
no dejaban que se registren, vale,
nosotros hemos sido participes necesario
en lo que fue la modificación para que se
contemple nuevamente el registro de los
títulos propios de la Universidad de
Barcelona en el Seneccit,
así que también inclusive con Ecuador,
como era 1 de los países más fuertes que
teníamos.
Realmente esto terminaba condicionando
sobre todo a ustedes, no a los alumnos,
porque tenían algunas restricciones que
no dejaban también tener una un estudio
fuera del país que que realmente los
condicionaba mucho, no,
pero entonces sí se sí se contemple lo
que es el registro de los títulos propios.
Sí, exacto, bien, excelente.
Qué otras dudas, preguntas aila,
en realidad nada,
yo creo que hasta aquí está sumamente
claro la parte sí.
Había visto que se adaptaba mucho la
parte de jornadas horarios para poderse
conectar a las clases pregrabadas
entonces como que no, no, no,
hasta ahí no tengo más dudas.
¿En realidad bien te quería preguntar
hasta aquí soy la qué te había parecido
en la escuela Universidad de Barcelona,
el programa, los rankings,
todos estos servicios extracurriculares
que te brinda,
que que puedes seguir desarrollándote y
actualizándote de por vida,
lo ves alineado de lo que tú estabas
buscando, te haces ilusión,
te ves haciendo este programa?
Me gustó mucho la parte de Freemaster ya
por ejemplo,
yo sí soy muy a mí me dicen acá que yo
soy muy en el trabajo,
entonces este a mí me gusta como que
constantemente estar actualizándome,
buscando cursos, preparándome.
Lo hago mucho online por mi trabajo,
porque por mi trabajo,
pues me demanda cierto tiempo y pues
entré es muy apegado a la parte de ventas
y pues ventas no duerme.
Entonces me gusta la flexibilidad que
existe.
Y me gustó, sobre todo,
me parece bastante interesante. Es todo,
o sea,
siento que integran muchas otras cosas,
no solamente la parte del de, la del,
o sea, del de la parte del estudio,
el enfoque en en los módulos,
sino también toda esa parte del liderazgo,
la compañía de la parte oratoria.
¿Me parece muy interesante este personal
branding que que tienen porque justamente
se acopla a lo que yo hoy en día,
a los pasos que hoy en día estoy,
estoy siguiendo entonces?
La verdad es que eso me pareció un valor
agregado muy interesante,
que no lo había escuchado en las otras
opciones que tenía.
Sí es que esto es lo que te comentaba al
principio,
no la diferencia entre una Universidad o
una escuela de negocio y en este caso
encima Escuela de Negocios de alta
dirección, bien excelente.
Me me me alegro escuchar escuchar esto te
te comento acerca del proceso de admisión,
zoila.
Es un proceso serio, protocolario,
donde se evalúa,
se puntúa a cada perfil profesional.
Yo Leo un informe.
Todo lo que hemos comentado va acompañado
de esta documentación que puedes ver en
pantalla bastante sencilla,
tu hoja de vida actualizada, el DNI,
el pasaporte de la célula, es decir,
una identificación personal tuya,
cualquiera de los 3,
otro copia del título y una carta de
intención, una carta de motivación,
no sé si había escrito alguna
anteriormente o sería la primera.
¿Sería la primera, vale? Bueno,
básicamente es una presentación de tu
perfil profesional solicitando una plaza
al programa y por qué ser tú la persona a
la cual se lo otorguen.
Vale aquí muy importante soila y sobre
todo en tu caso, que lo tienes.
Céntrate en tus objetivos,
en en tus proyectos,
en tu crecimiento a nivel profesional.
¿Por qué el tipo de perfiles se busca de
la escuela?
Perfiles ambiciosos que tengan en el buen
sentido de la palabra, por supuesto,
no que tengan un.
Una proyección,
un crecimiento y nosotros poder
acompañarlos,
porque luego tu caso de éxito es un caso
de éxito de o B. S bien, mira,
te comentó zoila,
no sé si has llegado a ver el coste
oficial del programa en la página web o
en el Brosur que te envié.
No a ver personal, enhorabuena.
Sí, por supuesto lo tengo en euros,
es y se cobra en euros,
pero te lo voy a convertir a dólares si
que a modo de referencia estoy tomando
Google,
pero para hacértelo un poquito más fácil
a TI no en tu moneda.
Mira el costo oficial del programa son
€16000 son 13900, perdón, 15000 dólares.
Disculpa que son €13900, vale, está,
está dentro de lo que tenías pensado
invertir en tu futuro profesional.
Un poco distante en realidad,
pero tendría igualmente que revisarlo.
¿Soyla tú querías abonarlo al contado,
ya contabas con un ahorro, con un colchón,
lo querías pagar todo en cuotas?
¿Cuál era tu tu idea? O sea,
lo tengo un valor en en mi cuenta no,
pero estaba viendo la opción también de
hacerlo con tarjeta de crédito o algo
similar, porque sí,
tengo aquí también opciones para poder
hacer.
¿Están los estudios o K está un poco más
alto,
pero estaba escuchando también que hay
opciones de becas, verdad? Becas como tal.
Nosotros no manejamos y cuando escuchas
esto también, zoila.
Te cuento media vuelta y corre también,
no,
porque ahí estás hablando con una escuela
para darte una beca.
Tú tienes que tener un talento
sobresaliente si tiene que hacer una
examinación, etcétera.
Y generalmente aquí te dan beca del 70
del 80% de lo que sea por no sé cualquier
etiqueta que le ponen.
¿Mujer emprendedora latinoamericana o lo
que fuera ahí? Bueno, tú sabrás,
todo está en la parte de marketing,
una estrategia de marketing,
te inflan un precio y luego te te dan el
que real YY realmente compiten por precio.
Nosotros como habrá visto en este caso no,
no competimos por precio.
Sí es cierto que tenemos lo que son los
apoyos económicos,
lo que pasa que eso lo literalmente lo
tenemos el día de hoy.
Yo estuve presentada en unos perfiles,
lo veníamos gestionando hace 60 días, no,
no es nuevo para nosotros.
Es lo que yo te iba a preguntar a ti
igualmente si no habría alguna
posibilidad,
porque sé que el día miércoles va a haber
1, pero es de de referidos, no tenemos,
para lo que son las convocatorias,
3 comités especiales,
donde puedes aplicar no solamente una
plaza,
sino también una plaza con apoyos
económicos. Es un apoyo parcial,
no es un apoyo total, pero mira,
estamos hablando de 6159 dólares, es.
Gigantesca la diferencia sustancial, sí,
lo que pasa como te digo,
esto lo tenemos el el día de hoy,
si tú lo tuvieras 100% claro,
yo le puedo preguntar al responsable de
admisiones si nos daría espacio de de
poder presentar tu tu candidatura y el
mismo día de hoy que tengamos el
resultado. Si somos admitidos ahí, claro,
el escenario ya nos cambia drásticamente,
pues bajamos de 13900 a €8556 te lo digo
en.
En dólares, disculpa,
de los 16000 dólares bajamos a 9862. Mira,
ahí vas a tener para venirte a Europa,
tú un acompañante,
darte una vuelta entera,
ir volver inclusive y te sobra.
Todavía realmente cambia mucho la
ecuación. ¿Bueno,
cómo se abona esto tú solo en caso de ser
admitida con los apoyos económicos
máximos?
Lo único que abonarías sería ahora la
matrícula. Sí,
tienes que reservar tu plaza,
que esto es el 10% = 986 dólares. Vale,
el 90% restante te queda en 14 cuotas.
Esto es sin interés,
la primera recién en abril,
que es cuando empieza el programa y te
queda en 14 cuotas de 633 dólares. Vale,
hablando de este escenario,
cuesta lo mismo pensar bien que pensar
mal, zoila.
¿Cuéntame cómo te quedaría a nivel
matrícula y cómo te quedaría a nivel
cuota? ¿También lo ves viable,
lo ves accesible? Sí,
lo veo viable ya más que nada como que
viéndolo el valor total sí se acopla un
poco más a lo que tenía estimado este
destinar.
Ya se acomoda mucho en realidad ahí con
el tema del apoyo,
pero la la qué tan o sea que.
¿Estadísticamente qué tanto?
¿Qué tan viable sería que este apoyo se
diera o no como para yo también tener?
Mira, estaremos entrando, sí,
un tema futbolístico en el minuto 90 te
diría porque el último minuto a a comité,
pero si nos dan el o K,
yo te digo una otra cosa, zoila, también.
Voy a acabar a ganador.
Si yo selecciono perfiles,
veo que tu perfil realmente tiene un muy
buen perfil.
Tiene sobre todo que esa es la parte
importante. Además la experiencia,
tienes proyectos, tienes ambición,
buscas un crecimiento y es el tipo de
perfiles que se busca de la escuela.
Lo importante no es llegar bien,
sino llegar también.
En este caso no vamos a llegar con con
toda la documentación tampoco.
¿Además lo de la Carta, olvídate,
yo te puedo presentar una pregunta antes
de de de de seguir con eso,
esa cuota la ves o K? Te pregunto,
pues vamos a agregar 1 o 2 cuotas si te
hiciera falta, pero lo único,
en vez de en abril empezar a pagar un
poquito antes en febrero por ejemplo,
y que sean 16 yo para que te quede bien a
nivel económico o la vez o k o sea,
se podría ajustar, se puede ajustar.
¿Sí, yo, yo, yo sobre todo por ti, EH,
para que te quiera una cuota más coma,
mira si fuera a partir de febrero,
por ejemplo, ya te baja a son 16,
pero de 554 en vez de 633 la ves mejor o
Prefieres en abril 500 te baja a 554
dólares? Sí, está bien,
no tengo inconveniente,
me acusa lo que acusa un poco de mucha
diferencia y una consulta. Ay, este.
De grabación.
Hay algún valor adicional que se deba de
contemplar algo muy buena pregunta,
muy buena pregunta. Soila el 100%,
absolutamente todo lo que te acabo de
comentar,
incluyendo el envío de la titulación a tu
domicilio,
ya está incluido en este valor total que
te estoy pasando. Vale,
y es muy buena pregunta.
¿Porque hay veces que no sé pagas 1 m b a
bueno, son 8000 dólares,
perfecto y luego te van a a titular,
bueno, ahora son 4000 dólares por latitud,
cómo 4000 dólares por la titulación si yo
la pagué los 8000 no? Bueno,
pero la titulación va aparte, no,
aquí lo tienes absolutamente todo
incluido, vale, lo único, único,
único que abonas extra son 150 €170,
que es el apostillado este de de La Haya,
que no lo podemos hacer nosotros,
pues no somos una gestoría,
De hecho nosotros.
Lo hacemos como servicio y lo llevamos a
una gestoría así.
Ya te lo enviamos directamente
apostillado también a TI, vale,
pero no tiene ningún tipo de dime.
Perdón llegaría.
Bueno, tarda,
tarda en cualquier Universidad de Europa,
te va a tardar entre año,
año y medio aproximadamente.
No es o b s no es la Universidad de
Barcelona en ese tarde,
sino el tiempo que demora el proceso para
que tenga validez legal aquí y en tu país
sobre todo también vale igualmente,
una vez que se cierran las actas que esto
estamos hablando.
Aproximadamente los 90 días de que
finaliza el programa,
ya se te envía un certificado digital que
tiene la misma validez que el título
físico,
solamente que él lo tiene en en formato
digital.
Y que hoy por hoy,
De hecho es lo que te te piden en las
compañías,
no te piden que te lleve el cartón el
diploma, sino el certificado físico. Sí,
soila, cuéntame cómo lo ves,
si tú lo ves o K yo voy corriendo,
consulto con el responsable de admisiones
y bueno, son 5 y cuartos.
Yo creo que en 1:15 H aproximadamente
podríamos tener la resolución que aquí ya
pasan a ser 3 escenarios posibles, B dos.
No puede ser admitida a secas, es decir,
al coste oficial,
lo cual va a ser una excelente noticia y
TEN en cuenta que algunos alumnos vienen
postulándose una, dos, hasta 3 ediciones.
A veces lo consiguen, a veces no,
a veces repiten el segundo escenario,
De hecho ese no ser admitido el programa
por esto que te comentaba son aulas
reducidas.
Se trata de seleccionar los mejores
perfiles que en base a Comité considera y
sobre todo que tengan este tipo de
proyecto para mantener la excelencia
académica que además nos solicita la
Universidad de Barcelona.
¿O el mejor de los escenarios será
admitida con los apoyos económicos
máximos? Si ese fuese el caso,
cualquiera de los trae igualmente el
resultado hoy te lo vamos a compartir.
¿Y cuáles han sido los motivos por los
cuales ha sido admitida?
Solamente el coste oficial no ha sido
admitida o ha sido admitida con los
apoyos económicos máximos,
ahora si ha sido admitida con los apoyos
económicos.
Ahí se te envía a ti un enlace a un
portal con usuario y contraseña,
ingresas ahí rellenas tu información
personal.
¿Aceptas las condiciones generales de
matrícula?
Y en lo bueno vemos la propuesta porque
yo ahora te la voy a enviar por escrito
también así te queda todo por escrito.
La comparamos que no haya quedado ya como
en la la propuesta final y en la última
pestaña haces el abono de la matrícula
así de los 900 y algo dólares que te
comenté. Vale,
yo te acompaño en todo ese proceso para
que no tengas ningún tipo de incidencia y
no nos envíen la lista a esperar.
¿Nos ha pasado alguna vez, por ejemplo?
Que era la tarjeta de El de la empresa
porque lo pagaba la compañía, por ejemplo,
y la tenía un director financiero y no el
alumno. Y bueno,
ahí no pudieron formalizar a matrícula y
se se reasignan esos apoyos porque a TI
te pasan la lista de espera,
pero no te preocupes,
yo yo te acompañé en todo el proceso,
vale o k o sea,
yo he estado el día de hoy,
tengo programado una llamada más,
es muy transparente, ya no sé si es.
Puede este o sea yo sí necesito igual
escuchar que usted sabe que es bueno
igualmente escuchar,
no hasta por hasta para poder tener la
tranquilidad de que la decisión que estoy
tomando con ustedes es la la correcta.
Ya este me gusta mucho,
me interesa demasiado, pero sí,
al menos me gustaría un poco escuchar la
la otra opción que justamente estaba,
creo que como para las 12.
Y con eso yo le podría confirmar.
A mí me interesa muchísimo y sobre todo,
me gustaría de poder acceder a hacerlo.
Con todo este apoyo económico que usted
ha mencionado se adapta mucho a yo estoy
jugando y a los valores,
que es más o menos tenía destinado para
el sistema.
Bien,
hay un el único handicap que que tenemos,
porque luego si que nos podemos postular
al al programa va a haber plazas porque
empiezan a abrir.
O sea que Estas son De hecho plazas con
apoyo económico,
que es por apertura de la convocatoria.
Sí,
es por eso que tiene un es como cuando tú
compras un pasaje de aquí a a agosto del
año que viene y te sale muchísimo más
económico que si lo compras en septiembre.
No es cierto.
Tú vas a poder seguir aplicando al
programa, pero ya sí, claro,
lo que es el coste oficial. Vale,
yo lo que puedo hacer soila, pero bueno,
también lo haría sólo a conciencia,
es decir, si tú lo tuvieras 100% claro,
y es cierto,
también soila que incluso si el día de
hoy nosotros hacemos todo el proceso de
matriculación y por algún equis motivo no
se encuentras que esta otra opción es
mejor.
¿O lo que sea,
no puedes continuar con el proceso,
se te devuelve el 100% de la matrícula,
eso que lo sepas y además es por ley
europea,
tú tienes 14 días de periodo de
sentimiento, EH?
Eso para dejarte tranquila,
que en todo caso no corremos riesgo
tampoco,
porque en el peor de los escenarios se te
devuelve el 100% obedece.
Ni la Universidad de Barcelona viven de
la matrícula de nadie,
así que por eso dejarte más que tranquila,
no correr ningún tipo de riesgo.
Pero bueno, si lo que necesitaría sería.
¿Documentación,
tú lo lo tienes medianamente a mano? Sí,
sí, sí lo sé, como en mi celular,
inclusive mhm, sí, bueno,
perfecto la carta, olvídate por la Carta,
yo ahora voy a hacer una extensión del
informe de tu perfil profesional,
le pido el responsable y te te
presentaría ahí como te digo en 1 hora 10
aproximadamente,
ya tendríamos la la resolución del Comité
YY bueno.
A partir de ahí, en crucemos,
lo lo veo en el mejor de los escenarios,
poder hacer el proceso de matriculación.
Vale, me das 1 minuto.
Zoila le consulto responsable de admisión
antes de de de generar tampoco
expectativas,
a ver si nos da el o KY nos deja aplicar
ya perfecto. Sí, está bien,
yo espero un segundito, por favor,
no hay problema.
Zoila, gracias por por esperar en línea.
Bueno, mira,
en ese sentido no nos ha dado buenas
noticias,
nos ha autorizado en caso de que quieras
aplicar,
si me dices tienes los los documentos a
mano, yo corro a a bueno,
formalizar lo que es el expediente tuyo y
ya hacer la presentación.
Le comenté un poco también esto que que
que me decías de que tienes esta reunión
con con la viewber no la.
¿De la Universidad de Valencia, De hecho,
ellos son parte del Grupo,
también son parte de Grupo Planeta de
Recuerdas que te decía que tenemos un
holding de veintidos Escuela de Negocios?
Bueno, view también es parte, me dice.
Realmente tampoco va muy alineado, no,
porque claro,
el ser una Universidad no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver todos estos
servicios que te comentaba que que que
vas a tener aquí no,
porque ellos están obligados en realidad
a tener 1 m b S por 1. Cuestión académica,
sí.
¿Pero a lo mejor ahí tú sí que irías
estudiar si fuera una carrera mucho más
investigativa de neurociencia o o ese
tipo de de carreras, no? En este caso,
claro,
al tú estar en y desarrollar todo lo que
es tu carrera profesional en El Mundo de
los negocios, claro,
se va mucho más alineado a esto,
pero bueno, evidentemente cada 1 averigua,
escucha y todo lo que lo que quiera,
no en ese sentido,
simplemente para para darte herramientas.
¿Zoila, bueno, la la, la pregunta,
quisieras aplicar a lo a lo que son los
apoyos económicos?
Sí, sí, me gustaría en realidad ajá,
porque sí,
sería como que una opción mucho más
viables si fuese así, vale y bueno,
nada lo que digo, zoila, igualmente,
por cualquier tipo de eventualidad que
tengamos o lo que sea,
que tengas la tranquilidad,
también que tienes ese periodo de
sentimiento de 14 días, sí,
así que nada también dejad de tranquila
por ese lado. Mira, dime una.
En el caso de que se dé ya hoy,
hoy y mañana feriado acá en Ecuador,
en el caso de que se llegase a dar este
valor de la matrícula,
hay opción de cancelarla en dos valores
de pronto y hoy o mañana un valor y a
salir el miércoles.
¿Creo que es ya día hábil,
al menos por el tema de mira te comento
generalmente hecho la matrícula es el 15%
que ya te digo exactamente cuánto es?
Son €1283, vale,
yo te he puesto la matrícula más baja
porque evidentemente haga esto,
lo tenía contemplado para un de 1 hora a
otra. Sí,
para poder hacerlo más fácil si lo que te
pueda ayudar a ti.
Si te hace falta hacerlo con más de una
tarjeta sí que lo podemos hacer,
por ejemplo,
sí dividirlo en 2 o 3 tarjetas si
quisiera y demás.
Lo único que sí qué pasa esto hay que
enviarlo a la Universidad a la hoja de
matrícula, vale,
y para enviarlo evidentemente tiene que
estar la reserva hecha.
Y esto que te decía, pues si no,
por ahí nos pasan la lista de espera,
que sería casi como perder lo que son los
apores tú lo que es la matrícula.
¿Tú manejas tarjetas Visa,
Master American Express o Diners? Sí, sí,
sí. O sea,
es que lo que pensaba hacer con mi
tarjeta de débito en realidad,
pero pero hacerlo con la diferencia.
Tarjeta de crédito, bueno, exacto, sí,
si quieres lo hacemos así, una parte,
una parte, no hay ningún problema, sí,
está bien.
Generalmente lo que menos incidencia
tiene es la tarjeta de crédito. Sí,
generalmente es más sencillo, vale,
te lo digo por si por ahí justamente si
no hay veces que tiene que llamar a la al
Banco y solicitar el porque tienes el
candado internacional puesto porque no es.
En dólares,
sino que es en moneda extranjera,
que es en euro. En este caso,
generalmente con lo que es la la tarjeta
de crédito no debería de haber problema.
No sé si tú la has utilizado para comprar
en Internet o comprar en el exterior
alguna vez anteriormente he comprado sí,
bueno, o sea,
en en un principio no deberíamos tener un
problema perfecto. Zoila,
te voy a enviar dos correos con esto,
yo ya voy finalizando a no ser que tú
tengas alguna otra duda o pregunta.
1 con ventajas y beneficios que tienes
con la doble titulación de o b s a la
Universidad de Barcelona.
El otro te voy a enviar la propuesta
económica si te queda todo por escrito y
la documentación necesaria para poder
aplicar al programa.
Me respondes directamente a ese correo
con los documentos. Olvídate de la Carta,
no, no,
no te preocupes por ello y si quieres
también te escribo un un Whatsapp,
así te queda en mi contacto directo por
cualquier duda.
Pregunto lo que fuera y si te parece bien,
nos volvemos a reunir dentro de 1 hora
exacta.
Ya con el resultado de Del Comité y bueno,
lo que te decía en el mejor de los
escenarios,
poder acompañarte en en el proceso de
matriculación demoraría 15 minutos,
20 minutos máximo. ¿Le parece bien?
Está bien de acuerdo,
excelente el tema documentos.
¿En cuánto tiempo me lo podrías tú enviar
aproximadamente para poder ir
organizándolo?
Yo creía que unos 10 minutos máximo,
o sea una vez finalizada.
Perfecto mientras voy avanzando con el
informe de tu perfil listo soila te te
cuelgo así voy corriendo con con todo
esto te dejo ya los dos correos,
te voy a dejar mi mi Whatsapp también y
te voy a mover esta misma reunión para
las 11:30 H vale ya listo o k muchas
gracias un placer hasta ahora. Bye bye.